British Army Chief issues call for
conscription and of uh and whole of n
Nation mobilization for war it's not
just Britain Sweden has issued a call
for their sta uh for their citizens to
prepare for war and there have been
reports that people have begun signing
up to be conscripted so in Sweden they
have a system where you f a
questionnaire and determine whether or
not you will be forced to join the war
effort France 24 says Sweden's call for
population to prepare for war Sparks
panic and criticism now I don't consider
the world socialist website to be all
that credible but here's the interesting
thing I believe conscription is the
appropriate word based on the facts
corporate news doesn't want to say
conscription because of what it means to
the average person so of course the
times.co.uk says UK must train citizens
for war with Russia says Army
Chief let me just let me just try that
one for you again UK must train citizens
for war with Russia